First, my name is Henri Santoso. Before
my religion is Roman Catholic in 2014, I
referred declar.
I have the question about your beloved
son
about speciality of woman Islam and
hijab and many more.
Yeah. Yeah. Please ask your question.
Okay.
formusl.
[Music]
for
she's asking uh he he's asking that if
there's a lady a Muslima uh she has done
her shahada and she has done her tba and
nuha however in the past she has a lot
of photos videos which are uh spread on
social media and she has committed other
sins so will Allah forgive her or how is
it
>> any non-Muslim who accepts Islam all the
previous sins are forgiven so if there
was a non-Muslim lady was in social
media the moment she accepts Islam she's
forgiven now in her past life when she
was the non-Muslim maybe she was a influ
social social media influencer and she
had photograph and all she should try
and remove all that. There is something
like copyright. If someone paid her she
cannot remove but if no one paid her she
can remove it. She can strike is my
photograph stop it. So she should make
an effort of trying to remove all the
photographs of her. But if she took
money from someone
for modeling that she cannot remove. for
that Allah will forgive her.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> But if she has not taken money and it's
circulating, she can easily stop by
putting a strike. It's my content. Take
it down. You understand now? So whatever
she can stop, she should drop. What she
cannot stop. Allah will not question her
because it's outside control. But then
she should say what I did in the past is
wrong. All the other Muslims should not
do. I have done Toba and she should do
more and more dava but what she did in
the past she will not be held
responsible. Hope
>> Thank you very much.